c'est le meilleur film à prendre
l'affiché cette semaine comme les texans
titre est une quête de vérité
en plus tout seul il raconte l'histoire
vécue de meriem est une journaliste et
productrice à l'émission 6 des ménages
aux états unis qui a dû se battre pour
trouver son intégrité et défendre sa
crédibilité après la diffusion d'un
reportage controversé sur les années de
service militaire de george w.bush qui
est blanche et incarne l'ambitieuse
journalistes avec à ses côtés robert
crippen dans le rôle de l'animateur dan
rather alstom pour porter ce scénario
complexe et parfois aride
le film fait appel à une impressionnante
distribution qui comprend dennis quaid
bruce greenwood et elisabeth moss tous
nous plonge dans l'univers du
journalisme d'enquêté en posant de
nombreuses questions éthiques
laissant le public tirer ses propres
conclusions ma cuisine sera bientôt la
meilleure du monde
dans un tout autre genre on retrouvera
des cooper dans le rôle d'un chef qui
tente d'obtenir ses trois étoiles
michelin
après s'être mis à dos les gens de son
industrie ses amis et des trafiquants de
drogue sache qu'au moins une douzaine de
personnes et sur l'avortement brûlés ou
brent en version originale anglaise est
une fiction qui tente de faire écho au
monde compétitif de la haute gastronomie
avec dans les rôles secondaires sienna
miller qu'ils aiment à thompson et
l'acteur français omar sy a lu mon vieux
ont fait la paix même si les images
magnifiques font saliver
cette histoire de rédemption à l'eau de
rose est très prévisible dit consommer
et vais oublier à temps
un nouveau film québécois prend aussi la
fiche cette semaine les démons est le
premier long métrage de fiction de
philippe lesage qui propose un scénario
racontée du point de vue d'un garçon de
dix ans joué par l'excellent edouard
tremblay grenier à travers de longs
plans séquences on découvre les
nombreuses angoisses de félix la plus
grande force des démons et de créer du
suspense dans des scènes pourtant
banales de la vie
chapeau aussi à tous les jeunes acteurs
ce film très peu bavard mise sur les
silences et la contemplation c'est une
qualité autant qu'un défaut parce que
certaines questions restent fâcheusement
sans réponse ici tanya lapointe radio
canada montréal